parce que il veut pas de escaliers il ne
comprend rien le Medvedev sont son
ancien président il veut pas la
désescalade ils font tous me la monter
la montée la montée et donc président
Macron là on a sciences Unies avant-hier
il a prononcé un discours très ferme il
a expliqué aussi aux Nations unies au
pays qui soutiennent Poutine qu'il faut
pas le soutenir il faut au moins lui
montrer qu'on est qu'on est qu'on n'est
pas derrière lui et y compris en ne
faisant rien parce qu'il y a plein de
pays par exemple les pays africains ou
les pays asiatiques qui ne sont pas avec
lui mais qui votent notre
la Chine
la Chine le soutient voilà la chemise
passerait en cas de en cas d'attaque des
Russes justement si la Grande-Bretagne
que vous l'avez dit derrière riposte
qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer parce
que c'est vrai que la Chine est quand
même un maillon important il ferait quoi
la Chine quoi en principe la Chine dit
je suis très loin les États-Unis disent
la même chose nous on est de l'autre
côté de les États-Unis bien sûr bien sûr
que si bien sûr que si donc en fait ces
armes nucléaires on a parlé d'armes
tactiques après vous avez les armes qui
ont les portées différentes vous avez
les armes de petites portées même pour
des canons qui ont déporté à 20 30 40 50
80 km même en nucléaire après vous avez
le nucléaire opérationnel c'est jusqu'à
200 km 300 km avec vous avez le
nucléaire moyen porté c'est jusqu'à 5000
km et après vous avez le nucléaire
stratégique
intercontinentaux et là ça peut aller
n'importe où sur la terre est-ce que Joe
Biden est vladim routine se parle non
malheureusement pas du tout donc c'est
ça aussi le parce que jobiden en fait il
a choisi la fermeté de langage face à
Poutine il a dit face à ce que Poutine a
fait abucha à
Erpen ce sont les villes selon les
banlieues dans le nord de Kiev où ils
ont massacré des gens massacré des
civils en fait on a découvert ça lorsque
les Russes se sont retirés le 31 mars
ils ont laissé ses villes et donc là
c'est c'est les Ukrainiens mais aussi la
communauté internationale qui qui est
venu et là c'est c'est l'horreur c'est
l'horreur et en fait président Macron
par exemple il avait il disait oui il
faut pousser les Ukrainiens vers vers la
paix pour conclure les
pots la paix avec les Russes y est allé
au mois de juin à Bouchara il a changé
de discours il a changé de discours
depuis fin juin président Macron a
complètement changé de discours et dit
Poutine mène une guerre impérialiste ils
sont fous de tout le monde et donc il y
a que avec une réponse ferme il dit que
l'Occident veut détruire la Russie c'est
faux voilà et est-ce que est-ce que la
France voilà c'est rien la question que
tout le monde se pose aussi ce soir
voilà on pense bien sûr tout le monde
mais est-ce que la France pourrait
être subir une attaque nucléaire la
France pourrait subir une attaque
nucléaire qu'on apporte quel autre pays
qui représente l'Occident donc
l'Allemagne la Grande-Bretagne les
États-Unis mais la France peut répondre
parce que la France est une puissance
nucléaire et le problème il est là aussi
parce que si la Russie attaque la France
au nucléaire la France peut et peut-être
répondra du point de vue nucléaire
est-ce qu'il y a des moyens de se
défendre oui la France a des moyens de
se défendre
en attaquant ou se défendre en se
défendant
se défendant parce que vous savez
d'abord on espère avec Poutine on espère
que la moitié de ces missiles sont les
missiles soviétiques et donc ils vont
peut-être même pas partir parce que ils
sont là depuis 40 ans ils sont là depuis
30 ans et donc ça se trouve que c'est
comme avec les chats vous savez il y a
plein de champs soviétiques qui sont
arrivés en Ukraine qui sont tombés en
panne voilà et donc on espère qu'il y a
peut-être la moitié des missiles qui
vont pas partir enfin comme ils ont
oublié c'est ça
le problème il est là c'est que il y a
l'autre il y a l'autre moitié qui qui va
quand même partir après les pays
occidentaux dont la France ont la
possibilité de se défendre avec les
antimissiles donc en France vous avez
les antimicides donc on peut rabattre
assez loin du territoire français les
missiles qu'on voit parce que dès que
les missiles partent de Russie on les
voit tout le monde les voit tout le
monde a des radars un missile qui
partent de Russie il arrive combien de
temps après on va c'est ça le problème
c'est c'est ça le problème parce qu'en
fait les anciens modèles de de missiles
et mettront peut-être une demi-heure 20
minutes mais ils ont actuellement les
missiles qui sont très rapides et donc
et d'ailleurs la même la même personne
la même femme là de de la chaîne de la
première chaîne télévision visuelle ils
ont montré aussi ce missile qui
s'appelle sarmat qui mettra 5 minutes
entre 4 et 5 minutes pour arriver en
faire la mer par la mer c'est plus
rapide c'est ça on peut se faire
attaquer aussi par la mer parce qu'il y
a les sous-marins il y a les sous-marins
scientifiques russes qui peuvent être
dans l'océan Atlantique et à ce
moment-là c'est juste quelques minutes